on
les toners
tourneur sur bois depuis 11 ans déjà
revenant la réunion après un séjour de
huit en métropole en tant que fraser
comment numérique pas moyen de trouver
du travail dans le fraisage en tout cas
à la réunion il n'ya pas vraiment ça et
finalement j'ai dû me recycler dans le
bois est aujourd'hui je suis vraiment
sur
épanouie dans ceux de ce que je fais
quoi on compte parce que j'aime ce que
je fais j'ai l'amour du bois et je
connais pas mal d'essence maintenant
avec le temps je suis tout le temps la
nature aussi vous dire donc la nature et
moir le travail ensemble quoi finalement
l'autre alors les pièces que je fais
c'est plutôt destiné à la table à la
cuisine entre topo la table il ya des
bols et assiettes complément gels et
bien sûr de lanvin c'est fait pour les
piles on chip ou la cuisine c'est la
tradition des bols postale allaient tous
a donc fait aussi sur commande des
pièces je réalise des pièces selon les
commandes selon ce qu'ils veulent les
clients vraiment moi j'écoute pas du
bois vers moi personnellement je suis je
vais la tuer je vais récolter prélever
du bois mort carrément pouvoir
travailler avec lui en fait la coupe ce
fait à la tronçonneuse et après il ya un
parti l'assise de la pièce justement que
je pense à un peu quand même pour avoir
un parti liste proposée sur le plateau
du tour pour avoir une stabilité sur le
tour qu'on fait et on peut pivoter de
lax du tour jusqu'à la gauche aux
données les formes pour creuser bon en
fait la partie extérieure plus souvent
d'abord et après on vient pas à
l'intérieur c'est la partie finale avant
le pont sage pour usiner la piètre faut
que l'outil elles soient bien tranchant
c'est ça qui fait toute la partie de
l'usinage en faites pas parce que c'est
l'outil elle est pas bien tranchante on
va prendre beaucoup de temps on va pas
enlever les copains on va plutôt
arracher la matière en coupe pas
vraiment il faut qu'ils ont une bonne et
si tranchants et là on travaille bien on
prend moins de temps 5 question de gain
de temps tout ça aussi et le travail
dans des conditions les petites
finitions il le fait à la main on se
retourne la pièce du tout en fait je le
fais en faisant en frottant un peu avec
un petit théâtre en fin de compte on va
avoir une bonne vraiment une bonne
finition aussi prête à l'emploi les gens
là elle soit du tour il dépoussiérez
puis on peut mettre la table décoration
les essences essentiel que je travaille
notamment le jacques lebas noir l'olive
l'eucalyptus aussi je travaillais rouge
surtout parce que le blanc est vraiment
exploitable après il ya le copo le congo
carrément jean luck offriez convient de
l'usiné là vous avez senti l'odeur des
gens c'est agréable ça débouche les
narines les bronches et tout ça ça
devient demi finales d'une part et c'est
agréable aussi à travailler question
dureté un densité de bois du coup ben je
prends un plaisir de travailler parce
que c'est facile c'est agréable là comme
vous voyez j'ai deux tamarins qu'est ce
que peuvent je préfère aussi un travail
et le tamarin parce qu'il est noble
c'est un bois deviennent ici comme je la
leur alors notamment la commune a
travaillé le camp sud a lancé de la même
forme dans les faits coucher toujours ça
c'est de l'olive qu'ont nos
grands-parents et prenez pour balayer
les cours à bec ou s'ils ne le prenez
aussi pour guise de rameau pour aller à
la messe
l'olive cette thaïlande voisine quand
même là cette taille là est la voisine
quand même plus d'une cinquantaine
d'années parce que sachant que ça pousse
dans les rivières beaucoup de lumière et
célébra c'est le trait dans son bois
barcelo a poussé et j'aime bien les
défauts naturel alors ce que je cherche
loi dans la nature ses déboires avec
plein trouble dans 20 des mictions
rentrer dedans en fait c'est la nature
qui a travaillé le bois avant moi je
fais que donner la forme après un dut
mettre en valeur les défauts naturel
finalement d'envoyer un peu les trous là
qu'il ya des dents et justement ça c'est
ce que j'aime je préfère le plus mes
clients aussi d'ailleurs et on garde son
côté naturel quoi finalement s est hissé
la pièce unique en fait
là